so i understand that this album took two
years
uh to create scott you know would you
say that this is like a true testament
to
uh just so much hard work and and just
so much love for this album
yeah i mean the album itself was a lot
of work we wrote a lot of songs for it
we had to arrange it find this like
perfect balance of pushing our sound but
also
keeping what we do so well um but mainly
the work was in
the years of growth we had to uh we had
to grow
so much over the past ten years
emotionally as songwriters
and so i think that's kind of where the
work was and then this album we were
like ready to make it
oh i love that okay so you know this is
your first full-length
original album since 2015. um
you know you just kind of touched on a
little bit but kevin what did you want
to say with this album
uh i think kind of tagging along what
scott said in 2015 that was our first
foray into original music and i think
we knew how to arrange well but it i
don't think our forte was
saying something specific to us because
we hadn't gone through a lot of life
experiences that i think
allow for an album to feel potent in
that way
and i think from 2015 to 2020 when we
were starting to write this album and
put it together we had all gone through
life experiences and individually
collectively
we had had love and we lost love you
know things like that that i think
make us really ready to speak on an
album like this and artistically each
one of us had also gone through our own
journeys as well
so when we came to the playing field we
knew ourselves so much better
individually so that when we put our
collective talents together
we could really speak with one voice and
so i think we're really really proud of
what this album
um has to say from us yeah you know
speaking of the album in 2015 you had so
much success with that
with that album so much success after
that you know when you put out another
album like this is there a sense of
pressure um to hopefully have it as
successful as your album in 2015
any sense of that or once you put it
into the world that's it you just see
what happens
matt
i mean i was just going to say that
there is always a little bit of
comparison that you're gonna do with any
project every video you put out
i can't help but kind of look at the
views compared to the last one and
read the comments i think that's just
human but i will say honestly and
authentically
um i'm not really comparing this that
much to the first album
because it's a whole different
experience and it's a whole different
chapter in our life
so i i'm not i'm not totally comparing
yeah well when it comes to the title of
this album i love the song the lucky
ones
matt is this a reflection of of you guys
as a band that you just feel so lucky
that you've been through all of this and
you're still here and you're happy
yeah i mean we're so happy and i think
you know
being in the pandemic and being you know
home we're always on the road we're on
the road like
i mean um i don't know how many months
out of the year it'd be
six to eight and so being home for like
a full year
has been this beautiful time of just
kind of self-reflection
and thinking about family and thinking
about you know getting engaged and other
people in so many life events and
and it's just been this beautiful um
time to like sit and think and just be
grateful for you know the blessings that
we have
in the in this time right now and um and
that and one of the big
biggest blessings is this band that it's
lasted so long the spin has been
together it's
friendship this family that we've
created and this body of work that is
just
that is going to stand the test of time
you know so it's really exciting
this is really reflective you know kevin
when it comes to
creating an album especially during a
global health crisis
did you guys sit up like at home
recording studios how did that all work
well i can say thankfully we actually
recorded most of this album before
the pandemic happened um it was funny we
had finished the last song before we
were actually supposed to go out on tour
in europe
in mid-march of 2020 and then the
pandemic hit and then we stopped
so we're very thankful that the album
was kind of done but i think
the pandemic actually gives more light
and more nuance to the album that there
are things that we say on this that i
think
make a lot more sense to us now that
we've had time to reflect on it and it
makes us that much more proud to put
this
art out in a time like this yeah scott
have you guys all missed each other
like is it weird that you're not all the
time
yes we have a lot actually and every
once in a while
we'll get to like run into one person
like like going into the studio and
everything
and you all be like oh my god it's so
crazy to see your face not on zoom
like hug me from a distance but yeah
it's like the best five minute
interaction that you could
let's catch up in five minutes
um i was just listening to your song
coffee in bed i just love it
so much matt who would you say drinks
the most caffeine out of all of you
oh caffeine
[Laughter]
with my like
probably scott i think i think you drink
coffee
i feel like people could guess that
based on my like energy level
all the time okay so what's your go-to
coffee
scott my go-to coffee lately has been an
ice matcha
with like a either a pump of pineapple
or chai in it
which isn't coffee but it's caffeine but
um also i like
i like just iced coffee with almond milk
oh
so good classic um you know this is this
has just been such a
strange time for so many people people
had highs lows in their lives
um how do you each uh maintain a
positive head space
scott let's start with you um i'll say
routine has helped a lot having a
schedule for myself every day so i can
just
if i'm not sure what i want to do or i'm
bored or i'm spacier i'm scattered
i can always just look back at that and
it's on paper that helps me i'm a virgo
that makes sense um but also trying to
stay active and outside and
productive i've been making like as many
tick tocks as possible
just anything creative i can do at any
time is very fulfilling and
exciting and makes the the stillness of
being home all the time a little more
bearable
yeah your tick tocks are so entertaining
um you know i think grounding myself in
the morning and remembering that
my job and i feel like our job
collectively as a band is to serve
and i still i think about all the music
we put out during the pandemic like the
at-home ep when i think about this album
i think how much more can we serve
people in a time like this that may not
necessarily have an outlet
like music we get to do this as our job
every single day that's
the most beautiful um
outlet you could have at least for me
and i think for all of us so
just constantly putting out music and
remembering this is a service has been
a really great headspace to be in i love
that what about you matt
i think um keeping connected to
you know my friends and my family um
they know this about me but when we're
always on tour
i'm always somewhere facetiming somebody
and so
i'm happy
and i just like because i it's it for me
it really keeps me connected keeps me
you know
in connection with people and knowing
what's going on it's not just over the
phone i get to actually see their face
and so it's like really been a a
beautiful thing to call my family and
talk to close friends and you know kind
of check in on them a lot have a lot of
friends
who are teachers and you know so it's
been a long a hard year healthcare
workers and so
just really kind of uplifting each other
and keeping each other you know
sane and happy and you know like you're
saying reflective on all the
gracious and gratitude of all the things
that you know we should be grateful for
so that's awesome uh you know there's
been
so much talk about representation and
diversity and
inclusivity especially when it comes to
music industry pentatonix is such a
great example of this
do you guys notice a change are you
noticing
more diversity more inclusion you know
when it comes to the music industry
kevin i mean 100
and i don't think a band like us could
have existed
if there was not that change in society
with more inclusivity and more diversity
you know one of the songs that i love
that we put out was
imagine and it was amazing because we
all could identify as five completely
different things but at the end of the
day we can come together with our
differences and make beautiful music
in one harmonious voice you know if we
can do that with all of our differences
you know
geographically sexual orientation so
many different things
i think we can all do that as a as a
country as a world
as a society so i'm i'm happy for the
change and i hope that it continues
going forward
i love that um is there this is maybe
like asking your favorite child but
scott
is there one song on the album that
really resonates with you
oh man this is a hard one you know
i mean coffee in bed is always my go-to
favorite probably because my
we all had different muses but my muse
when writing that was definitely my
boyfriend mark
um who's kept me sane in this pandemic
so that song just means a lot to me
and then bored and then lucky ones and
they love me when i don't
know all of them yeah that's amazing
what about you matt
i would say bored i think because it's
it's you know i just want to be bored
with you like i just want to just
watch movies and we just started the the
um
the marvel series in cinematic order so
yeah
we're just like we're in it we're like
deep in
you know engagement you know cute level
high
you know so cute
yeah we're the board is like the song
it's it's
i love that song love it what about you
kevin
man i always go back to a little space
that one is such a bop i'm always it's
so funny i remember
the first time we actually had a mix of
that and i was getting a haircut and i
was
playing through the album for my uh my
barber and then a little space girl
thought it goes whoa
hey hi bro and i was like that's what
i'm talking about
so that one is just it always gets me in
a good mood i love that one
yeah also i have to reveal because a
bunch of people like we're like who's
singing on it
kevin's actually singing the verses of
that not singing the pre-choruses
oh so it was fun to be able to change up
solos there
first exclusive
thanks guys got the scoop um you know
it's hard to probably even imagine
what's next for you guys you know you
put up this
album so much hard work goes into it but
what is next for you guys you're working
on your music
are you just waiting for you know this
time to be over so you can go back on
the road what's
what's like the goal i mean all the
above i mean we're always writing we're
always thinking about
music we put together like a medley
recently that we're working on
um we want a tour as soon as it's
possible with all this exciting news
about
vaccines by may i'm like can we do a
christmas tour
obviously i know this is cliche but it's
all up in the air but we are
always brainstorming about what's next
yeah oh i love that well
you have just such a die-hard fan base
people love
your music thanks so much for your time
guys it was really nice thank you
awesome